[Music]
foreign
remember
[Music]
hello and welcome to Sophie Ridge on
Sunday it's been a week full of stories
about who's in and who's out in Telly so
let me be clear Sophie is just taking a
break and the bosses here thought that
on a Sunday bank holiday weekend you
might appreciate a bit of Sky's answer
to Antiques Roadshow I'm Trevor Phillips
Sky's hit show succession builds to a
climax this week this morning
Westminster writing its own dramas
swella bravaman reckons her Thriller
stopped the boats might pull in the
viewers in TV we usually want more
people on board the Home Secretary wants
fewer foreigners Landing here
the political Rivals are working on a
very different script the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt wants more less well-paid
workers to keep the wheels of the
economy turning and inflation down but
over in emergency Ward 10 the Department
of Health they're tearing their hair out
because the hospital sets falling apart
and there just aren't enough doctors and
nurses to play all the parts
and on the Rival Network labor they've
been trading new shows for months more
doctors more houses more jobs but
they're yet to tell us much about how
they're actually going to deliver
still it's a year or more before we know
who's going to top those election
ratings stay tuned for 60 Minutes of
gripping viewing
in just a moment we'll hear from the
health secretary Steve Barkley
and for labor I'll speak to the party's
Shadow work and pension secretary
Jonathan Ashworth
with new claims about Boris Johnson and
plenty of other stories of sleaze once
again in the papers we'll talk to the
chair of the standards committee that's
Labor's Chris Bryant
someone likely to write to the defense
of the former prime minister is a
conservative Arch brexiteer Andrea
Jenkins
and we'll try to cut through the
political noise about immigration
following those record net migration
figures this week and get some facts
from the chair of the migration advisory
committee Professor Brian Bell
[Music]
thank you
there's been a flurry of announcements
from the health department this week
everything from more patient choice to
use of Technology
but the fundamental problems in the NHS
crumbling buildings staff shortages and
pay disputes plus huge backlogs and
waiting lists that remain the Remain the
big worries
so let's start this morning with the
government and just a few moments ago I
spoke to the health secretary Steve
Barkley
you promise to rebuild five hospitals by
2030 because they're full of this
particular kind of concrete that will
make them now fall down
um some of the other hospitals that you
promised to rebuild are now going to be
delayed so what about the other 29 that
the NHS
has already identified as liable to
collapse well we were clear in our
Manifesto we were going to build 40 new
hospitals and the statement on Thursday
made clear that that's exactly what
we're going to do but of course what NHS
leaders have said to us is those five
rack hospitals as you say the ones with
concrete where there is a risk a risk to
the building fabric it's right that we
prioritize those so of course we're
following the evidence and the evidence
shows that those five hospitals are
priority cases it's right we respond to
those the ones that are then impacted by
that are still part of the new hospitals
program it's just they may not be
complete by 2030 which is the original
Target date we set in the manifesto so
we're committed to those hospitals
they're still part of the program we'll
be working on them and sorting enabling
works on those schemes but it's right we
prioritize the rack hospitals because
there's a an urgent need to do so so to
be clear and there's no shame in this
you are not going to fulfill your 2019
Manifesto pledge of 40 new hospitals we
are going to by 2030. we are going to
fulfill it by 2030 that's what we were
very clear the five hospitals are coming
into that scheme which will be completed
and I'll tell you how it's by embracing
modern methods of construction in a
similar way to the way that we have in
education in the ministry of Justice
with prisons as is common in the private
sector to building much more in
factories using modern methods of
construction that speeds up the approval
I get of those schemes but also the
construction time of those things are
bringing those into the program I get
all that you can do you can do new
things I started life as an engineer so
I knew things move on but just to be
clear I thought you just said that you
would not be able to make build those
29 other new hospitals to get your
target to 40
by 2030. will there be 40 new hospitals
by 2030 or not right there will be 40
hospitals by 20 42 hospitals 20 of these
schemes in the program will start
construction next year a number already
have and will they be completed by 2030.
the commitment is for 40 new hospitals
by 2030 we're bringing in the rack
hospitals within the scheme because
independent reports
very St Edmonds they're urgent and we
need to address those so just to be
clear all 40 are going to be uh spanking
new hospitals open for business by 2030.
there'll be 40 new hospitals in line
with the announcement in 2020 where
there was a number of cohorts cohorts
two three and four the cohort one
schemes were already underway those
schemes will now proceed the cohort 2
schemes for example is telling me that
they'll be ready by 2030. well I think
I'm being clear there will be
seems complete by 2030 they will include
the five rack hospitals there were some
within the list that will be part of a
rolling program that will go beyond but
that's because five have been added to
the 40. all right we could go on about
the the chop the words for for all
morning
and if it's helpful indeed indeed so um
the the problem with with this pledge is
that you did say you'd build this 40 new
hospitals and now telling me it's gonna
happen you originally said that there'd
been eight of them built by 2025 so far
you've managed two
it's not that persuasive that uh you're
going to build the 40 by 2030 given that
you haven't even got the eight by 2025.
it's a very fair Challenge and let me
explain why we're changing our approach
as a result nine of the last ten
hospitals built in England were over
time and over budget and that's because
what quite often happens is as the
scheme starts the specifications are
changed people come along with their
bells and whistles and want to change
what's in the scheme by taking more time
and having a standardized approach
What's called the model 2.0 hospital so
a standardized approach that allows us
to bring all that expertise into one
design then go out to Market and have
the economies of scale that the NHS
offers and this is something that's very
common in the private sector we've
already done it in education and in
prisons it is a fundamentally different
approach for how the NHS will build its
buildings but that's how we will
accelerate the program by using modern
methods all right instruction okay we
will revisit this or somebody who's
sitting here will revisit this with you
in a year's time
um now the RCN annual conference Pat
Cullen general secretary said that you'd
emailed her and agreed to me how did
that meeting go oh we had a very
constructive meeting uh this week uh
working with Pat Pat obviously was
deeply involved in the original
negotiation she recommended that deal to
her own members she said that it
constituted really yeah they said no
though well she negotiated the deal with
me and the rest of the staff Council she
said it was real progress uh tangible uh
yeah no more what she said her members
said they didn't like it they want more
than 10 are you going to give it to them
well the NHS staff Council agreed to the
deal so the majority of Health unions
accepted uh the AFC deal that's why that
will go into pay packets uh in June
because we hugely value the work that
NHS staff do that's why
she said there's going to be more
strikes uh this morning are you saying
to Pat Cullen doors open we're we're
going to move towards you to your art
Target more than 10 or are you saying to
her
look you know the the staff Council
decided this you're getting the money
that's it forget it I'm saying what Pat
herself said which was it's not there
and finally you have to ask me what
you're saying and and being consistent
and what Pat said at the time that the
deal went to members was exactly the
same as what I said and what the rest of
the NHS staff Council said which was as
a fair and final settlement a five
percent uh pay increase plus a lump sum
it means a band Six uh entry nurse gets
over five thousand pounds over the two
years recognizing the huge valuable
contribution that NHS staff have made
okay what some in the RCN I'm asking
this to do isn't legally possible it's
not possible to give a band Six nurse a
different pay to a band Six Midwife or
against six paramedic because they're
great so they're rated the jobs that
they evaluated in the same way but Pat
herself said this was real progress she
recommended the deal
we all know what Pat said but what
matters is what her members said and
they said they do not like the deal that
you've negotiated that has been accepted
by the staff Council they are a big
Union and what about a third one
yeah
whatever Pat may or may not have said to
you in your meeting the point is her
members don't like it and what you're
telling me and I'm uh forgive you know
tell me I'm wrong the words I've picked
out of your answer there are full and
final what you're saying to them is
that's a lot well we're going to make
that payment in tune to all uh over a
million uh you've told me that but this
is the you're not going back to
negotiating table with the RCN well not
on the amount of pay there's things in
the deal that we agreed with the NHS
staff Council where there is further
work around pay progression uh around
violence against staff around pension
abatement there's various things with
within the deal and we've agreed a
package of work with the NHS staff
Council to take those forward but this
is something that the stuff Council as a
whole voted on unions like Unison over
70 supported this deal and we will get
this payment out to people in their June
settlements okay
um one of the other things uh in that
discussion with the nurses is the long
delayed Workforce plan which you
promised in November 2018 any chance
we're ever going to see that well the
chancellor committed to the long-term
Workforce plan in the Autumn statement
uh it is a big complex set of proposals
it's right that we take our time to get
the detail of that right we will bring
that out uh soon but it needs when it's
soon four and a half years is not soon
well it was announced in the Autumn
statement that we were bringing this
forward obviously
had a pandemic and various things that
have been happening in recent years but
the Autumn statement gave a commitment
from the chancellor to have a long-term
Workforce plan it's something that
Collies in NHS England have been working
intensely on we need to look at both the
additional numbers and how we grow our
domestic domestic Workforce but also
what reforms we can put in in terms of
using our skills better using new roles
within and within the NHS in different
ways so it is a complex piece of work
it's right we take our time to get it uh
as it should be but we will bring that
out very soon I I respect your your
answer but when you say take your time
you've already taken four and a half
years the Chancellor's committed okay
fine is the chancellor committed to
paying the money that any Workforce plan
that's to go into the detail but it's
going to cost you money has he committed
to paying for it well of course any
expansion of domestic Workforce will
come at a cost there's a cost in terms
of the the training itself there's cost
from higher numbers in terms of the the
pay for those roles as well but it's
also about looking at what reforms we
can bring forward as part of that plan
but of course these are discussions we
have on a cross-government basis and
that will be part about the
announcements actually I can sort of
hear a sound there and it feels like the
sound the I say with cans being kicked
down the road again now I'll be very
clear the plan will come out very
shortly it will be shortly before the
next specific date well yeah before the
next one absolutely very shortly uh but
I'm not going to give a date this
morning a huge amount of work has gone
in so guys uh and uh you know it's
something that we're having discussions
on as we speak okay the chancellor has
appeared in our conversation already
this morning
um he said to my colleague Ed Conway uh
Sky's data and economics editor on
Friday uh when Ed asked him if he was
comfortable with Bank of England doing
whatever it takes to bring down
inflation even if it precipitates a
recession Jeremy Hunt said yes because
the inflation is a source of instability
there's nothing automatic about bringing
down inflation it's a big task but we
must deliver it and we will your last
job I think was in the treasury
um recession is a price worth paying
you're okay with that well we're being
clear the prime minister just as five
key commitments includes growing the
economy and I was very pleased to see
that the RMF rated uh our growth 0.7 uh
increase so we do need to halve
inflation we need to grow the economy
and we need to reduce debt and that is
why those are the first three key
commitments from the prime minister in
terms of okay there's five pledges even
if it means a recession with attendant
levels of unemployment impact on living
standards and indeed by the way uh
impact on public spending which means
you probably won't get the money that
you want from the treasury that's all
fine or acceptable if it brings down
inflation no if it brings down what I'm
saying is we need to grow the economy
that's the second of the prime
minister's commitments and the IMF said
that the chancellor had acted decisively
that was reflected in the up rating of
our great forecast from the RMF just
this week so growing the economy is one
of the prime minister's five pledges
we're committed to doing so just as we
are to cutting waiting time so my focus
in terms of the health secretary through
announcements this week like on patient
Choice empowering patients Association
saying that to take three months off
people's waiting times that's what we're
focusing as they know that we we've got
a glimpse of honesty from from the
chancellor uh
Mr sunax pledge one bring down inflation
pledge to bring raise growth sometimes
those two things are going to be in
conflict and the Chance has been very
honest he says
inflation is number one target for a
reason and if that means you know that
we have a recession so be it doesn't
want it but it might be why can't you
say the same well do you disagree with
him you started you started the
interview talking about the cost of the
new hospitals program and clearly one of
the areas where inflation has an impact
is on construction costs building
materials uh double digit increase at
the moment so the impacts on inflation
is important to the NHS but what we have
seen from the Prime Minister and from
the chancellor is their commitment to
funding the NHS 6.6 billion contributed
at the Autumn statement additionally to
the NHS and most importantly up to 7.5
billion for adult social care because
how we integrate Health social care is
hugely important so for priority at the
Autumn statement was Health and Social
care funding and we can't make that
problem let's just get to the number of
what the difficulty is here all this
means borrowing and the cost of
borrowing is climbing we had a look at
the uh the bond yields and here we can
see it look you're up to uh get four
point four and a third percent now which
if I if I read it rightly this is the
highest April figure for borrowing cost
since
1997. you are not going to be able to
afford any of this because of the boring
course are you well as I say the RMF uh
commented this week that the chancellor
yeah that appeal to the IMF because you
every time they just say that that
you're in trouble you say what a load of
rubbish they are let's just deal with
what usually you quote them in the
interview I don't I'm not coaching them
so I'm just responded to I didn't quote
them this is your numbers but my focus
as health secretary is to get the
waiting times down and that is what
we're doing if you look at the contrast
between our approach in England which is
working where two-year weights were
eliminated virtually in the summer uh 18
month Waits down below 11 000. if you
look at the contrast where in Wales it
was 74 000 for 18 ways
that obviously is looking at the
economic side but what we're doing on
the health side but again
point is you were responsible at one
point for this role and you know with
boring costs at that level the
chancellor cannot do all the things that
you've just been talking about well
that's why the Prime Minister has set
out the five pledges he has in terms of
having inflation growing the economy
reducing okay but the fourth one is the
one that and the poor inflation went up
the fourth one is the one core inflation
went up from I think six point two
percent to 6.8 which is why you've got
those interest rates climbing well CPI
has come down uh and it's good to see uh
that coming down so inflation has come
down but we need to to go further but my
focus as health secretary is on the
fourth approach cutting waiting times
and just look at the contrast between
England and Wales on two years weights
on 18 month ways well Wales with a much
smaller population has around 74 000
patients waiting more than 18 months we
got that down so below
and I I won't say say it for you late
Wales got labor governments on here you
say want to cut waiting times one of the
ways you're going to cut waiting times
is by having more people in hospitals
more doctors and nurses because that's a
control Factor
um
wants to reduce the number of people
coming into the country let's just first
ask you this
um do you think that people who voted
brexit understood that when you said
Take Back Control that meant uh
controlling immigration to the highest
net number in our history 606
000 this week well as a brexiteer when
people talked about taking back control
it was about the ability to decide who
we bring in and what works best for our
economy and that's why we are expanding
the medical Workforce more than 5 000
doctors
saying that they were saying to control
in order to bring it down not to get to
six hundred years to things like stop
the the small boats and the illegal
migration legal migration
but on doctors we you're right we do
need more doctors and nurses in our
hospitals that's why we've got over 5000
more doctors over 11 000 more nurses
than this time last year so we are
increasing our Workforce Now part of the
So when you say that when you say that
to the Home Secretary she says oh
absolutely Stephen absolutely I
completely agree what we need to do is
to make sure that even though I'm going
to bring the numbers down to she said
last year less than a hundred thousand
we're going to make sure we have more
doctors well the Home Secretary is
absolutely right on the need to bring
the numbers down and the Prime Minister
uh reaffirmed his commitment to bringing
the overall numbers down I think there's
a distinction to draw between for
example some of the abuse of student
Roots people coming in on a student visa
and then changing looking at the number
of dependents and we announced this week
a tightening of controls particularly
where people are coming on undergraduate
student courses and dependents are
coming as well so there's areas of
course the numbers have spiked because
of Ukraine and Hong Kong more than 100
000 from you yeah come on over 50 and I
think that's something most people
actually welcome and accept come on but
it has been come on well the ons no no
you're one of the few politicians that I
know can actually add up you can do
maths you reduce the numbers from 600
000 to Oak below one hundred thousand
half a million uh people out of the
immigration figures where are your
doctors and nurses going to come from
well if you have if you're if you're
stopping half a million people we're
confused with nurses are you I think
we're confusing two different things so
firstly 600 000 legal migration which
includes your doctors and nurses I think
as the ons themselves said there was a
spike because of Ukraine on Hong Kong
which I think most viewers except was
the responsible thing for the YouTube
when you strip out the I think it's
about 320
000 ukrainians and Hong kongers he's
still got more than four or five hundred
thousand well which is why on Tuesday
the Home Secretary announced a
tightening of the rules particularly
around dependence of students looking at
some of the enforcement of our students
so there's things there and in terms of
the medical community and the NHS it's
two things we do need International
recruitment that is something that the
NHS has already always relied on but we
also need to grow our domestic Supply
and that's what the long-term Workforce
plan which quite rightly you highlighted
earlier is about growing supply all
right look before I let you go uh I'm
sorry to say this but there's one person
who can see never seem to uh get out of
the news and that is your former prime
minister Boris Johnson
um
is it all over for him he claimed he
says that the uh claims that are uh
being made about yet new issues for him
are all nonsense
um he's got his hand over the cabinet
office has to hand over uh the
unredacted WhatsApp messages from him to
the covert inquiry and he's now got
himself a new legal team so it's all a
terrible mess but is Boris Johnson toast
no no I think Boris has a huge role to
to play we saw his leadership in the
country's response to Ukraine uh where
he took the the lead on that I think
that yeah but we saw a lot of other
things but I just want to talk to you
about where Boris Johnson is now do you
want him back in the next Parliament uh
of course I want all my colleagues back
in the next party Johnson to be back as
a as MP for Uxbridge with all the
distractions and we're talking about him
now of course I I want to see Boris back
uh as a member of Parliament and I want
the cabinets for the the Prime Minister
that's above my pay grade but the point
is uh you know Forrest achieved many
things the the speed of the the the
kovid roll out so look at our response
in Ukraine if I take my announcement
this week the new hospitals program the
40 new hospitals was something he has
championed including uh for Hillingdon
in his own constituency so so there's
many things that I've worked with with
Boris so you so you're signing up to
bring back Boris uh campaign are you
trying to characterize things in in
different ways what I'm saying is within
the house fear what I am focused on is
empowering patients more that's why we
made the announcement this week on
patient choice but also getting that
investment into the NHS estate and we
also have the four new hospitals
announcement which is the biggest
investment of capital in our NHS uh
Hospital estate over 20 billion pounds
Steve Barkley thank you very much indeed
that was the health secretary Steve
Barkley let's get the view from labor
now the party says it would reform
welfare to tackle a crisis in sickness
related work absence so let's talk to
the shadow work and pension secretary
Jonathan Ashworth good morning Mr
Ashworth
good morning just let's just start if we
may with um the report that KIA stammer
wants to stop all new oil and gas
exploration is that true
Well what we'll be doing in our coming
weeks is outlining how we want to uh
invest in the green jobs of the future
to bring bills down to create a more
sustainable energy Supply we'll be
outlining that in a significant mission
in the in the coming weeks and we'll be
announcing more details then but we know
we've got to move to more renewable
sources of energy it's the it's it's
important for our climate change
commitments but it's also the way in
which we can bring energy bills down for
consumers
interesting sounds very much like a a
yes uh Mr Ashworth um and if you do stop
all new oil and gas expiration with
Old Fields being shut down
where does that leave your
celebrated windfall tax uh number one
and number two doesn't that mean that
you're going to ask Britain to rely in
the transition to Net Zero next 30 years
or so on supplies from other sources for
example Qatar perhaps even Russia again
uh no this isn't about shutting down uh
what's going on at the moment we will
manage those sustainably we do think of
windfall taxes they're not inexhaustible
if you stop all new exploration you are
going to have to fill the Gap from
somewhere and it won't all come from
wind we know that that the the the sums
have been done so where is it going to
come from this character it's a
mischaracterization to say our policies
all from win we think we need to invest
in yes we do need to invest in Wind we
need to invest in Tidal we need to
invest in nuclear we need more
sustainable sources of energy Supply in
order to bring the bills down for
consumers and actually create jobs in
this green transition there are hundreds
of thousands of jobs that will come
online from a transition to low carbon
Industries and Technology it's not just
directly in the uh energy and the energy
sector but Associated jobs in
manufacturing in design and Engineering
we should be a world leader in this and
one of the things that I want to do in
the way in which I reform welfare reform
the job centers is prepare our Workforce
for the next wave of jobs which is
coming the next sets of opportunities so
that we are ready for these high skill
jobs of the future
all right let let's talk about the first
term uh in your title which is work uh
as you say jobs and let's talk about
who's going to fill those jobs when
we've still got a million vacancies
um legal migration
uh the labor home former labor Home
Secretary uh Alan Johnson reminded
everybody yesterday that the present
point system was introduced by labor
um you weren't there at time but do you
think that the then labor government
um of Tony Blair
foresaw that it would lead to the
highest net immigration figure in
history
well that that high figure that we're
discussing is on the conservatives watch
and they gave us from the system that
you introduced let's let's not blame the
Tories for everything it was your system
well well by the way I wasn't an MP then
and this government has been in power
for 13 years so I'm sorry that I'm going
to focus on the 13 years of this
government and not something that was
happening when I was at school in
University look the immigration system
we want to see migration lower than it
is but immigration is in many ways a
reflection of your health of the labor
market and when you've got a million
people unemployed today and a million
vacancies when you've got 700 000 young
people neither in work or training or
education and when you've got hundreds
of thousands of over 50s and people who
are currently signed off sick but say
they would want to work if given the
right support then I believe we should
be Skilling people investing in people's
trading fixing the red tape and
bureaucracy in the apprenticeship Levy
but also fixing the way our welfare
system works and our job sensors work to
give people the skills and opportunities
to move into work ministers cannot even
tell you how many of that 1.3 million
people unemployed are non-benefits are
actually on a training program they
don't even collect that data I think
that is utterly hopeless when we know
that firms are trying to fill vacancies
in this country today all right you you
your party wants to be in government so
let's if we were made just talk about
you rather than uh do a critique of the
the current government
um you have advanced a policy I
understand this week of restricting
employers right to bring workers from
abroad uh putting in new hurdles there
and regulating pain in order to force
them uh to train British workers is this
a return to Gordon Brown's Mantra of
British jobs for British workers
now what this is is about saying to
firms we you should be investing in the
workforce that you've got on the
potential future workers by investing in
their skills and retraining
opportunities rather than pulling the
lever of going straight to International
Recruitment and undercutting the wages
by cutting those wages by 20 we don't
think that that's fair but as I say when
you how are you going to force them to
do that
well well we would actually this is
about the uh these are the rules
associated with who are on the uh the
the shortage uh occupations list so we
would enforce that these are this is
about government statutory regulatory
rules so we would enforce that but the
second thing is that we would do which a
labor government would do is we're going
to reform the way our job sensors work
we're actually going to give more power
and responsibilities to local areas so
they can redesign the types of training
that is on offer to the moment all you
get if you go to a job center all you
get is essentially CV writing training
well when you've got AI coming along
which is going to write the CVS for you
you really need a new way in which you
can train and retrain people and upskill
people for the future so that's one of
the things we're going to do and here's
a very significant welfare reform that I
am proposing if you're off work for
reasons of sickness at the moment and
you've been through something called the
work capability assessment that acts as
a disincentive for you trying to return
to work so I will give people an into
work guarantee by reforming those
assessments so reforms to look to the
apprenticeship Levy reforms the way job
sensors train people reforms the benefit
system reforms to the immigration system
that's a substantial package of Reform
to get more people back to work and more
people into the jobs of the future thank
you well let's dig into that because you
talked to this morning about exactly
that program of work one of the things I
noticed in your announcement you talked
about a tailored job support is that um
code for 14 people back to work
well the moment people who are on it's
now called Universal Credit as you know
Trevor but essentially the old job
Seekers related benefit there are
conditions attached there are conditions
attached to people claiming those
benefits and we will keep those
conditions we will want people to move
into jobs but we'll also offer people
decent training and reskilling
opportunities at the moment you get sent
to us but I don't think that's good
enough but but they're offered that
already and I I'm interested in this
because uh you know it's what
governments do they are honest with the
people and it seems to me that what you
are saying is that you are going to be
tougher on people who are currently on
as you say Universal Bennett or sickness
benefits uh is that correct
well I I I mean the word tougher has
brings me all kinds of connotations I'm
going to have a fair system well it's
just a fair system giving people giving
people the support and the help that
they need to move into work let me give
you an absolutely astonishing statistic
older people out of work and sick and
disabled people out of work even though
many of them say they want help to move
into work only one in ten are getting
any support to move into a job I think
that is absolutely extraordinary and
he's writing off
huge numbers of people who have got huge
who've got huge potential to contribute
and who say they actually want to work
so we've got to reform this job center
system and we've got to reform the way
in which our benefit assessment system
work they are some of the Practical
reforms I am putting forward which will
help people get back to work because I
don't think it's acceptable look
actually the government actually copied
some of my reforms they said they're
going to do it but actually they're not
going to do them for years and years
they're relying on International
recruitment all right
thank you very much for your time this
morning
thank you
you're watching Sophie Ridge on Sunday
this week with me Trevor Phillips still
to come on the program this morning
in just a moment I'll speak to the labor
chair of the House of Commons standards
committee that's Chris Bryant
and a little later we'll hear from the
conservative MP and brexiteer Andrea
Jenkins
but first let's get some immediate
reactions from our Deputy political
editor the guru Sam coats who's been
watching all our interviews so um what
have you heard that interests you this
morning
I thought what the interview with Steve
Barkley the health secretary Drew out
very well was just the sheer scale of
problems facing the government at the
moment were you were quizzing him about
those 40 hospitals that were promised by
2030 the truth is he couldn't quite
bring himself to say it in as clear
terms as this but they've pushed eight
of the 40 back to the other side of 20
30 because they're having to cope with
other problems but that's just one issue
in the intree of ministers at the moment
at the top of the list pretty much is
that there are red flashing lights on
the dashboard of the economy yes the IMF
did say that the government growth
forecast they had upgraded Britain's
growth forecasts but there is a big
looming problem the cost of borrowing as
you were putting to Steve Barclay is
going up that's going to make doing
things for this government more
expensive it's also going to push up
millions of people's mortgages if the
economy is going to get worse and growth
is potentially going to stall because of
that and I think the Tories are in for a
very difficult year when they thought
they were going to be able to rely on
some green sheets
okay thanks Sam and thank you by the way
I got that to boring figure from your um
your long read on the Sky News website
but we'll we'll talk more about it later
on thanks very much
foreign
to say that Boris Jones Is Never far
from the headlines but I think we've got
to roll it out this week as the former
prime minister was once again all over
the news with new allegations of
lockdown breaking and Diaries passed to
the police then there was a row between
the covered Inquirer in the cabinet
office over his WhatsApp messages and
then another argument over his
government-appointed lawyers
oh well Sky News spoke to him
exclusively in the United States and
this is what he said about those new
claims
this hopefully is a load of nonsense
from beginning to end and we made that
clear in the statements that I've issued
um I think that it's ridiculous that
elements in my diary should be
cherry-picked and handed over to
the police to the Privileges committee
uh without even anybody having the the
basic common sense
to ask me what these entries referred to
what do they refer to there is
absolutely nothing in those entries that
constitutes uh rule breaking during
covid restrictions okay mingling with
friends at Checkers no that is
absolutely not what those diary entries
show that is not what those diary
entries show and the whole thing is
totally nonsensical
well look if you can find our way
through the Merc this coming Tuesday is
a deadline for the cabinet office to
provide unredacted WhatsApp messages to
and from Boris Johnson to the covert
inquiry plus the House of Commons
privileges committee is due to deliver
its verdict suit on whether the former
prime minister Middle s misled the house
and that's likely to provoke another
Almighty round and in just a moment
we'll speak to the conservative MP and
Boris Johnson supporter Andrew Jenkins
but first let's talk to the chair of the
committee on standards uh Chris Bryant
thank you very much for joining us
um now we've just heard Boris Johnson
flatly denying fresh allegations of
lockdown rule breaking and so on he says
nothing
to see here
um and I know you can't get into the
details because you're chair of the
standards committee but um what's your
immediate reaction to uh his assertion
well the the trouble with Boris Johnson
is that we have heard him deny things in
the past which has subsequently turned
out to be true I I can't remember the
inverted what was it his line was an
inverted pyramid
yes I can't remember what what that was
but anyway it proved to be completely
and utterly true and not an inverted
pyramid of purple at all so
um and and it is true that sometimes
Boris Johnson finds himself innocent in
the court of his own opinion but
um and you're right I'm very hesitant to
get into the specifics of this case
because
um a there's potentially a police
investigation B there's the Privileges
inquiry which I'm not party to I recuse
myself
um from sharing that because I believe
that I I already had a view as to
whether Boris Johnson has misled
Parliament and done so recklessly or
deliberately and that might be Mr Bryant
uh well yes it's very publicly known I I
think he did it seems to me self-evident
that if you turned up to events
um at which uh which was subsequent for
which we were subsequently fined you
probably knew that there were events
going on in Parliament that didn't meet
the legal requirements
um and that you weren't abiding by your
own lockdown rules and there were
parties in Parliament and therefore what
you had told Parliament was not true and
if you then chose not to correct the
record in time or at all ever in fact up
until this day then probably you have
not only
um accidentally or inadvertently misled
Parliament you've probably deliberately
done so or certainly
um allowed the misleading of parliament
to stand and that is a culpable contempt
of parliament in my view but I'm not on
the committee so that's almost
completely and utterly irrelevant what
the thing that worries me most at the
moment if if I might forever is
um so we've got the covert inquiry we've
got the police investigation we've got
the in the the inquiry by this
privileges committee we've also in the
last week um had the ministerial code
um uh a decision on the ministerial code
in relation to swallow Braverman
I think that was an odd decision but be
that as it may that's yet another body
that's been doing an investigation and
you also have
um this week there have been uh stories
in the Press today that MPS have been
claiming or some MPS have been claiming
and speeding or parking fines on their
expenses
um and that is regulated by yet another
body which is ipsa the independent
parliamentary standards Authority
yeah may I just asked you actually I
want you to come to that point about uh
MP's claiming uh the cost of parking
fines on their expenses two things first
of all um are you going to be
investigating that
through your committee number one and
number two from what we know the rules
at the moment is that actually wrong
uh well as I was about to explain
weirdly
um the rules on expenses are governed by
ipsa a separate body and my committee
the standards committee has no power to
investigate
um well in fact we can't investigate
anything it's only the Parliamentary
commission for standards investigates if
he thinks there might have been a breach
of the rules and then reports to us and
then we adjudicate on them
um but ipsa is the stats of the body so
it's laid down in statute law and it has
a um uh an officer who is there solely
to decide whether people have breached
the um the rules and they would then
refer things to the police because it's
the criminal offense to to
um uh false accounting or break or
breaking their laws on
um parliamentary expenses so no we can't
investigate
um it uh to my mind it is manifestly
wrong
I don't care whether it breaches a rule
it is manifestly wrong for somebody to
you know if you're an ordinary member of
the public you can't go off and uh if
you uh parked uh if you've been caught
parking in the wrong in the wrong place
at the wrong time or not having getting
a parking ticket or a speeding fine you
can't claim that on your daily expenses
can you so I don't see why this could be
a why why MP should be any different
sadly sky is not that kind to to us and
um of course we have to say that we we
don't know who those MPS are and they
can't be here to answer for themselves
but um you set up the principle very
clearly
um
there's a general issue I think which is
now building up which is the
relationship between politicians and the
Civil Service
on Tuesday the cabinet office has a
deadline and that's a deadline for uh
sending the unredacted versions of Boris
Johnson's WhatsApp messages to the
covered inquiry covered inquirers
demanded them
um do you feel confident that the
cabinet office is behaving correctly and
that the inquiry is getting what it
needs from the government
well I I read you know you can't believe
everything you read in newspapers as you
know but
um I I read a newspaper account which
seemed to suggest that the covert
inquiry was having to use
um Powers which incidentally not even my
committee the standards Committee in
Parliament has
um and and the covert inquiry has them
under the um inquiries act to Fourth
government ministers to provide things
um there shouldn't be you would have
thought that
what is the fundamental principle of
good government that openness and
transparency
um is there the ministerial code says in
terms that no Minister shall ever refuse
to provide some information unless it is
um legally necessary to do so and and so
I think there's a danger here that if
the covert inquiry doesn't get
everything it needs in a timely fashion
that it will feel to the British people
as if ministers are trying to obstruct
um a proper inquiry and and that will be
both a break for the ministerial code
and morally offensive there are lots of
people you know I mean my constitutions
still want to understand why so many
people died in Care Homes
um and there was no proper ring of
protection put around them and people
were sent to Care Homes so I think
people want to know the truth is all I
was going to say and sorry one month one
month sorry to bang on but one other
thing My worry is that we have so many
different organizations and so many
different rules that is actually very
difficult for the public and for that
matter politicians to understand but
who's it who's who governs who regulates
what particular bit the ministerial code
the civil service code
um I think all of this is right for
reform the whole system is simply not
fit for purpose anymore
okay
Chris Bryant thank you for banging on
with us this this morning no that's what
we're here for thanks very much for your
time
right let's get what I anticipate might
be a slightly different perspective now
a very staunch Boris Johnson supporter
seen wiping tears away as he left
Downing Street I want to speak to the
conservative MP and Deputy chair of the
brexiteer ERG group of Tory MPS Andrea
Jenkins good morning
good morning Trevor I'm no longer Deputy
chairman um but by the way but um yeah
I've I've stepped down from that when I
became a whip and a minister so but um
but but you are still
um an extremely influential voices voice
in those circles I am told
um look there there are lots and lots of
questions as ever swirling around Boris
Johnson
um
how do you react to what Chris Bryant
has to say I mean both the words that
Chris Brian used but also the
overwhelming sense of distrust and
um uh almost I suppose contempt for Mr
Johnson
um before I answered that um which I
I'll obviously answer Trevor you know
because I'm quite blunt spoken can I
just um go back to what Jonathan Ashwood
said for one second
um he was just in the job centers but
we've doing amazing stuff I was briefly
the skills Minister you know we have the
boot camps which you can get the
technical skills the hgv skills we've
got Kickstart to help people to write so
it's not just about the CV building I
just wanted to put that on the record
now regarding um I mean look we know
that Chris is as outspoken as I am but
on the other side of the fence and his
never like Boris and if anything there's
there's a real hatred from the left
um of Boris Johnson which I haven't seen
um since you know Thatcher's funeral to
be honest and I do think it's unfair I
think lines have been bled where the
civil service is consent I mean for
um you know for some Civ previous civil
servants to come out and publicly say
um that I you know was responsible for
bringing Boris Johnson down
um when you see that um you know part of
um the inquiry we hear that the head of
Ethics brought their own karaoke machine
to the Civil Service party yeah Boris
got the blame for Stuff
um the all these parties so I I would
like to see greater transparency not
only if the Civil Service have got this
orchestrator campaign and they are
trying to like stop our immigration
policy Etc I think we should need to see
more transparency um with the Civil
Service and they declare their interests
and their relations with not only the
media but with Shadow cabinet as well
I I
I'm going to come back to to ask you
about uh the the what you said about the
civil services you mentioned several
times but just before we get there
is Boris Johnson not responsible for any
of this I mean is he a sort of totally
innocent party
I I think if anything Boris has probably
been too trusting
um you know a Boris foreign
along all of this and um just wandered
through and been you know the victim of
awful devious other people
no at the end of the day I mean I I I've
seen the hatred out there and the
vitriol that's why outside down history
I got frustrated you know the the left
work got what they want and I think that
the need to leave Boris alone now but it
carries heavily pregnant just leave him
alone and what I really do question
Trevor is the timing of this
um so you're slightly you're being a bit
of a politician here you're sliding away
from my my basic question here whatever
you say about what's being said about
Boris Jones are you just saying that
he nothing he has done is worthy of
question or inquiry and he made no
mistakes no I every prime minister and
I'm not and I'm not evading the question
here um Trevor but every prime minister
you know should be questioned I mean
this is why I'm questioning our current
prime minister oversight and policies
like dropping annual welfare Bill and
you know I I will be a Critic I was with
Theresa May in our own party but with
Boris I do feel that no clearly that you
know he um he nobody's perfect without a
doubt um but there has seriously been a
lot to hear you say that but no but this
is honestly there's been an orchestrated
campaign not only in my own party as
well because let's face it you know most
of my and fellow MPS are the one nation
to the left of the party they've got the
leader that they wanted
um in Rishi um they never accepted Boris
and ever accepted list trusts and they
are they're out of sync with a party
membership who are big Boris fans
about the important point you made here
really which is about the role of the
Civil Service
um do you think it's right that the
cabinet office handed over boris's
Diaries to the Privileges committee and
as a result they ended up in the hands
of the police
I'm going with my personal view on this
my personal view is you know no and and
why did it uh they should have at least
let Boris Johnson know
um that they had Constance but I go back
to the timing of this why all of a
sudden when the covert inquiry is
wrapping up and
um we saw with the um with a committee
um that um that didn't really
um it wasn't strong evidence I didn't
feel I thought Boris came out very well
in the committee
um so I just questioned the timing of
this as well to be honest well as you
say you've been pretty blunt I mean
you've been pretty blunt on WhatsApp and
um I think we've seen some of your
messages this week
um
you talked about hypocrisy and
sanctimony
um yeah do you want to tell us names and
names who are you talking about
um well I mean the the person at the top
Simon Hall
um are sharing um Teresa May's time you
know he was quite vitriolic on social
media had to block him in the end so the
say about Blue on Blue and um you know
let's keep this in house Etc but those
who throw the first stone you know that
they
um that they need to make sure that
they're not divided to do the same thing
okay
who who else is in the enemy crew
I mean a lot of enemies I mean I have to
set the record straight with this um you
know we'd all much rather see the uh a
conservative government than a socialist
government
um with all their wokarati agenda so
um I mean I also blocked um the chief
Witcher in that time
um who's now the chief whip so you know
these to me
sorry with with the greatest of respect
I mean you know and I'm I'm a novice in
politics but I have to say well if you
want to see a conservative government
um yeah these WhatsApp messages bring
back Boris and all of that uh Rishi
always a bit weak uh all of the things
that you've been saying that they don't
seem like the best message to send to
the electric if what you want to do to
get the conservatives re-elected
I I mean um look I
I Boris and Liz was a prime minister's
and you know the party leaders who I
supported I didn't support Rishi and um
you know that's life under Theresa May's
time we um I mean when Boris got elected
we saw members of the party who wasn't
happy with that but I mean ultimately we
do want to see a conservative
um elected and and if anything Trevor
what I'm trying to do I'm trying to be
outspoken which I can't be anything else
I'm a Yorkshire woman and I'd be brought
up to be honest and blunt
um and if if anything I'm trying to you
know actually challenge some of the
policies that's coming out at the moment
too because I know what policies are
working in my area and actually to live
to deliver on our Manifesto commitments
okay just very quickly on yes or no so
being blunt Rishi sunak you want him to
be leader uh when you go to the next
election you're happy you'll get you're
you're gonna stick with it now
well as I've said publicly I am I to me
it depends on the polling Trevor I mean
this is me personally
political suicide to um look come on I'm
a pragmatist doesn't like to be pretty
political suicide it's a change leader
again now because we'd have to go into a
general election and what we'll end up
with 100 seats why would you do that I
want to see a conservative government
elected it sounds like Richie's on
probation have any of the no confidence
let us gone gone in yet
um I haven't a clue you know you'll have
to understand you you haven't submitted
one have you I mean I know you've been
yeah
I'm very public look when I submitted
one over Theresa yeah I was public about
that so if I if I'd submitted one
um you know I would put it out there all
right look the last last point I just
want to ask you on behalf of my dear
friend and colleague Sam Coates
um when he broke the
story on on Thursday you had to go at
him I mean honestly
I mean honestly you're impuning the
Integrity uh of one of the best
reporters around and with it the entire
sky crew I feel perfectly printed no
come on Trevor I like Sam and um and
you're pretty decent as well but but
come on we know that the media that
they're waiting to you know stories to
hear that the party's falling apart but
but we're not you know if you look at
I'm sure the labor MP is WhatsApp you
know you get people who's happy and not
happy and it's been very leaky for the
eight years that I've been an MP so
that's politics okay
and by the way that bbbj hashtag I
didn't quite get what it meant
bring back Boris Johnson of course yeah
I mean not that he wants to come back I
don't believe he does but Andrea Andrew
Jenkins we we really ought to do this
we really ought to do this again thank
you so much for your time this morning
otherwise have a good day bye-bye thank
you
gosh so that's the first time an MPS
described me as pretty decent anyway
let's get back to uh other message
you'll be forgiven for being a bit
confused when it comes to migration home
secretaries once again in the Sunday
papers promising to bring migration
numbers down something home secretaries
and prime ministers have been doing for
years
the migration numbers went up yet again
to a new record all of course after
we've left the EU here's the state of
play over the last two years last year
net migration the number of people
coming here minus those leaving hit more
than 600 000.
so what's going on uh well I can speak
to someone who should know and that
studies the facts Professor Brian Bell
is chair of the government's migration
advisory committee and he's here with me
good morning Professor Bell
um we can see the spikes in that
migration uh in the last couple of years
um a lot of people come here from on
schemes from Ukraine and Hong Kong and
so on but actually there is a longer
term Trend isn't there can you talk us
through what the underlying numbers are
and why they're so high so I think that
chart's quite a useful chart in the
sense that
um if you strip out the big changes in
the last year or two we'll actually have
a Long Run net migration number of
around 200 to 250 000 so the sort of
numbers we were seeing 2017 to 2019 will
actually be where we'll get back to
within a year or two the big rise in the
last couple of years three three big
reasons one the humanitarian schemes
you've mentioned an increase in students
the universities have been recruiting a
lot more International students in the
last couple of years and there's been an
increase in the work visa program some
of that's temporary and so we will get
those numbers down they will come down
in the next few years we'd expect to
around about quarter of a million but
they won't go any further than that
that's where the long run trend is
leaving aside the humanitarian uh issues
um can we talk about
watching the government's controls as
you said the government's made some
changes to rules on workers and students
um
do you think the government's policy
itself has contributed to these
increases uh well I mean clearly it has
I mean the government has for example an
International Education strategy that
says that universities should aim for
600 000 International students the
universities have delivered that but you
have to issue visas to those
International students so inevitably the
net migration number goes up similarly
um you know most of the work route uh
the majority of visas on that work which
issue to the Health and Social care
sector which is the one bit of the
economy that the government control so
you know if you're going to bring in
nurses doctors social care workers
you're gonna have to issue visas for
them are you as confused as the rest of
us by one part of government saying
let's kick up the numbers more students
more people in Health Service and so on
and another part of government saying
let's get it get numbers down to the net
number down to a sixth of what uh they
currently are well I think there is a
problem that um if if the government
says we are we have an objective of
getting that migration down to a certain
level they haven't actually come up with
an explicit number but if they're
committed to doing that you can't then
say but we need more visas on this route
we need more visas on that route there
needs to be some consistency I think one
thing that would be helpful would be if
the government focused on the long run
numbers so don't worry too much about
the fact that it was 606 000 this year
we understand why that was and the more
interesting question is if you get back
to the average of about 250 000 is that
acceptable and if it's not you will have
to change policy to bring it further
down oh that's interesting so for
example you might think of a metric that
looks like I don't know a three year or
a five-year rolling average as the way
of understanding what's happening yeah I
mean in some sense that's exactly what
you need to do because otherwise you
come up with perverse policy I mean
everyone supported the humanitarian
schemes for Ukraine and Hong Kong I
don't think a single politician spoke
out against it well that inevitably
resulted in a couple hundred thousand
extra visas it will be bizarre if our
policy response to that was let's
instantly slash some other part of the
immigration system for that temporary
increase let's think about the longer
term and the more sort of stable
position so one change might be the way
in which we uh the headline figure uh
but which uh the government advertisers
yeah so indeed you could I mean you know
there's nothing to stop
um the office of national statistics
publishing a range of numbers and they
could publish numbers trying to strip
out for example temporary factors to see
what a bit like in inflation we often
look at the core inflation rate to focus
on what their underlying inflation
Trends are rather than the headline rate
there are a couple of um peculiarities
in the numbers which I've looked I've
seen and other people have picked up on
um for example there are more Nigerian
dependents of students then there are
actual Nigerian students now of course
you know any student might bring partner
and a child but it does seem quite an
odd balance so there's been a big change
in the last couple of years and the
government have obviously focused on
this and their policy announcement this
week
um I think part of it is probably the
type of courses that students are
choosing to do so I think some of the
expansion that we've seen are in one
year Master's programs in more
vocational areas and that's likely to
bring in an older demographic than a you
know a straightforward master's degree
that's more academically focused so
perhaps it's more not surprising that
they're more likely to have families
with them okay the other thing which I
was um as interested I I did not know
this we include Brits coming back to the
UK in these numbers the 1.2 total who
are coming in and so on um and their
account actually for eight percent uh
name one in 13 of the numbers
um does that make sense well it makes
sense to count them because net
migration is trying to measure whether
the population is going up or down and
if more Brits come back from abroad then
go abroad that is increasing the
population so it's right to include them
I think it would be probably more
sensible if when we're thinking of
policy to forget about that group
because I can't believe there's any
minister in any political party that's
going to start legislating against
freedom of movement to British people
into Britain let's talk about what is
actually possible government says
migration is too high
um the opposition we don't not quite
sure what they but they think but they
certainly don't want to be higher
um do you think it is actually possible
uh by an act of will to bring down these
num numbers by more than a sort of
accidental number to say reduce them by
I don't know a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand quarter of a million I
mean in one sense it's absolutely
possible because the government has
control of the immigration system so
having left the European Union we
control all elements almost all elements
of the immigration system so if they
want to bring the numbers down they can
change the the rules I think the
difficulties as we referred to earlier
is the difficulty of getting that past
all the other government ministers that
might have other priorities so for
example you could ban all workers coming
into Britain that would definitely
reduce the migration numbers it would be
a pretty dangerous strategy to follow
but you can you know and so the question
is where do you tinker and um where do
you draw the lines well it's interesting
um last week uh sandton Selden who's a
vice Chancellor uh and baroness Martha
Lane Fox the tech entrepreneur talking
about education and business both said
that more worker migrant workers and
students were essential
um is there anything really substantial
that the government could do that
doesn't also kill either the education
system or the uh or or the economy well
so let's think if the economy is a good
one to think about so
um we bring in um 100 in the last year
we brought in a hundred thousand workers
on the Health and Social care Visa so
that's they were much they account for
about a seventh of employment in Britain
but over half of all work visas were
issued to that sector so how do you
bring in the immigration down well you
have two choices you either just ban
immigration that will cause Devastation
in the Health Service or you I don't
know come up with a Workforce plan for
the National Health Service you pay
social care workers better and you
actually create the circumstance in
which more domestic workers want to work
in that sector
well uh the Labor's come up with another
proposition which is that companies pay
that which can currently pay workers to
fill shortage um jobs as defined by by
you employers can pay them 20 less than
British workers
um if that policy were enacted what
effect do you think it would have do you
think it would work
to bring down numbers but would it have
other consequences so um I should start
by saying that this is a policy that the
migration advisory committee is
recommended to the government for the
last three years we never supported the
idea of uh employers being allowed to
pay below What's called the going rate
because the going rate is there to
protect British workers from being
undercut and to protect migrants from
being exploited by bad employers so
we've always supported that I think
actually the government is broadly
supportive of that so I don't think
there's necessarily a big political
divide here and it won't have an
enormous effect on numbers because
actually the number of occupations that
are eligible to pay below What's called
the going rate is quite small and even
when they're eligible to do so our
numbers suggest that about 85 percent of
jobs aren't actually filled below the
going rate so it won't change the net
migration numbers really very much at
all what it'll do though is protect
British workers and protect migrants and
that's important in and of itself
Professor Bell thank you for um a shaft
of clarity there thank you so much
indeed
that is it for this week's Sophie bridge
on Sunday in a moment after the break
we'll run through today's interviews and
see what we learned I'll be joined by
our Deputy political editor samcoat
thanks for being with us this Sunday
morning
[Music]
foreign
thank you foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back this is Sophie Ridge on
Sunday the take this morning with me
Trevor Phillips
this part of the program is a chance to
look back at our interviews this morning
and try to work out what we've learned
and what it means for the week ahead I'm
joined as usual by our Deputy political
editor Sam coats
good morning Sam now we talked a little
bit about
um the conservatives uh speaking as
Andrew dunkins tells me the Hammer of
the Tories what what do you make of uh
what we've heard about the party's own
difficulties this morning
well this week Scotty's brought you news
of the skip fire going on inside the
conservative party that was the phrase
used by Jackie Doyle price now she's a
conservative MP and she wrote that the
Tory party risks becoming a skit fire as
it engulfed in yet another round of
internal debate conversation and Route
about Boris Johnson because even though
he was two prime ministers ago
conversations about the former Tory
prime minister just dominate they suck
the oxygen out of the room of British
politics making life so much harder for
uh Rishi sunak his uh his successor and
I think what you heard this morning was
the fact that I mean this is like Steve
Barkley and having to defend him uh that
labor figures like Chris Bryant are just
a Gog at the sheer number of inquiries
that kind of mopping up that's having to
be done after the Johnson regime and
then Andrea Jenkins uh conservative MP
very much uh into bringing back Boris
Johnson as that as that hashtag on the
uh message that she sent suggests uh but
the the party cannot escape and until it
can escape Boris Johnson uh it's going
to really struggle uh to take off and
have a decent chance for fighting that
next general election so what really
struck me this morning uh Trevor was the
Ghost of Boris Johnson just everywhere
you look in British politics why is it
that they can't
if you like get themselves off that drug
I think that's a very good question it's
partly because uh some of them perhaps a
minority worry that the kind of
political talents that Boris Johnson
still has for all the problems uh were
the key to the 2019 general election
Victory and that without those you're
not going to get a repeat of uh that in
2024 which has seen that too much of a
technocrat too much of a sort of
managerial figure but I think there's I
I actually think there's simply an
unhealthy Obsession in some senses uh
with uh with with with Boris Johnson
there's so much mopping up to be done uh
that you end up sort of the party ends
up defaulting about it it's almost like
the conservative party's great big
displacement act to be discussing uh the
former prime minister because it's not
like there aren't other challenges you
put them to Steve Barkley very well
whether it's the rising cost of
borrowing the problems with the 40 new
hospitals in the NHS uh or issues around
migration like the big big big problems
here but it's easier to have an
archeology about Boris Johnson amongst a
lot of MPS than it is to confront those
really intractable issues that can't be
solved really when there's no money left
well hold on for a second and people
will sometimes say this is a media
Obsession and that the former prime
minister Boris Johnson is back in the
headlines following fresh claims and so
on is us but the truth is he's called
the allegations total nonsense but when
I asked the health secretary Steve
Barkley whether Mr Johnson's time in
politics appears to be over he wasn't
quite as uh
categoric as I expected him to be
I think Boris has a huge role to to play
we saw his leadership in the country's
response to Ukraine where he took the
the lead on that I think that yeah but
we saw a lot of other things but I just
want to talk to you about where Boris
Johnson is now do you want him back in
the next Parliament uh of course I want
all my colleagues back in the next party
Johnson to be back as a as MP for Alter
Bridge with all the distractions and
we're talking about him now of course I
I want to see Boris back uh as a member
of Parliament and I want to see all my
background maybe uh back well the
covenants for the the Prime Minister
that's above my pay grade
it's really striking time isn't it
because it would have been very simple
for Steve Barkley to say you know Boris
Johnson is a former prime minister we're
grateful to him for everything he's done
but he really now should uh enjoy a
period of silence and let us get on with
it but
Steve Barkley who's sort of mainstream
in the party I think couldn't bring
himself to say that
no I I mean Johnson's kind of a drug
that the consensus party can't sort of
uh wean itself off in some senses
um I suspect the fear uh from Steve
Barkley who is not somebody who
particularly likes to um draw strong
battle lines when he gives interviews
occasionally the kind of uh nuances uh
every answers nuances mean that the
overall message slips through your
fingers when Steve Buckley is uh is
talking but I suspect the reason why uh
you had a kind of on the one hand on the
other answer from Steve Buckley he's
just you know here man Downing Street
just too afraid to pick an a massive
open fight with Boris Johnson there's a
there's a behind the scenes fight going
on that's because uh it's people in
government who've been handing over
stuff to the police allies of Boris
Johnson very much gunning for the Deputy
Prime Minister Oliver Dowden who they
see as responsible for that Danny Street
I think trying to keep her lid on that
skit fire at the moment in order to stop
that bursting through uh and causing
themselves kind of big political
problems in the public Arena so trying
to be nice about him respecting the the
minority of people who are hardcore
Borough supporters that are still in the
party and hoping this goes away is
pretty much the only tactic that Daniel
Street has
okay well of course everybody's got an
opinion not just Tories uh I asked the
chair of the commons standards committee
labor MP Chris Bryant about Boris
Johnson and he pointed to a large number
of Investigations currently going on
into a range of MPS that highlight some
politicians poor Behavior
so we've got the covert inquiry we've
got the police investigation we've got
the in the the inquired by this
privileges committee we've also in the
last week um had the ministerial code
um uh a decision on the ministerial code
in relation to swallow Braverman I think
that was an odd decision but be that as
it made that's yet another body that's
been doing an investigation and you also
have
um this week there have been uh stories
in the Press today that MPS have been
claiming or some MPS have been claiming
um speeding or parking fines on their
expenses
foreign
it's it's so interesting there's all of
this swirling around and
um let's move away from Boris Johnson
himself for a moment but I think there's
a school of thought that says that the
Johnson period in government has
affected if you like what's acceptable
in Westminster now you're as Andrew even
Andrew Jenkins acknowledge your kind of
top Observer of all of these things it's
do that make sense to you
um if I was to pull the camera out a bit
a bit wider I think that uh in the last
20 years there has been a move some
steps towards a kind of much more
fiercely partisan uh form of uh
political uh uh a politicization of some
bits of our politics I don't think it
started by any means with Boris Johnson
I think you can see trace of it traces
of the kind of Direction we've been
going in uh going back to Tony Blair and
to Gordon Brown and certainly by the
time you got to to David Cameron and
that's and what I mean by that is uh
kind of
a sort of politicization of some of the
uh bodies that carry out inquiries into
politicians and MPS and sort of
complaining not because you believe that
there's a problem but because you want
to uh attack your enemy uh and uh
perhaps mounting more partial attacks on
uh on uh on your political opponents
that don't have quite as much basis on
Truth as they wanted I think I I think
this has just been an accelerating Trend
across the last uh 25 years really I I
think there will be some who point to a
particular acceleration under under
Boris Johnson certainly uh there have
been there's been an awful lot and he
was ultimately slung out from office
because he did not uphold standards in
the way that his own conservative MPS
felt was necessary it was the handling
of the affair around uh his friend Chris
pincher that was the final straw for a
majority of conservative MPS so he left
under a cloud because of Standards but I
do think there is a there is a bigger
picture here I'm not sure uh whether
this can ever all be put back in the Box
I suspect that I the the sort of level
of shouting has has not gone away and
won't go away all right let's
have listen to what Andrew Jenkins had
to say after a trove of leaked WhatsApp
messages between MPS was laid bare this
week because I think this issue of
infighting that you've just raised Sam
uh is has raised its head again
um now she talked about hypocrisy and
sanctimony which is what you normally
say about the other lot but when I asked
her who she was referring to
here's her answer
Simon Hall
um are showing um Theresa May's time you
know he was quite vitriolic on social
media had to block him in the end so the
say about Blue on Blue and um you know
let's keep this in how succession but
those who throw the first stone you know
that they
um they need to make sure that they're
not devote to do the same thing um I
mean I also blocked the chief whip Joe
in that time
um who's now the chief whip
I thought it was very interesting in the
last thing you said Sam that you went
back into the labor years where actually
all the political uh drama was within
new labor between Blair rights and
brownites and to some extent in the last
10 12 years with the conservatives in
government we've seen something similar
that all the political drama is not
between the major parties but within the
governing party is that new
um I I I mean I think every every set of
internal terminal has its own uh has its
own distinctive features I think that
um whereas during the labor years there
were two clear polls one represented by
God brown one was Episode by Tony Blair
who were who were clashing clashing
clashing through many of the years and
all the acolytes had two poles to sort
of rally around uh over the last 14
years when you've had a conservative in
Downing Street uh the kind of battle
lines have shifted there has been a kind
of touring right that was put in its box
by David Cameron at the start that is
now much more vocal much more kind of
radical and much more aggressive here 14
years on you know
that was Andrea Jenkins having a pop at
Simon Hart who is the chief whip she
says she uh muted him uh for some time
uh absolutely clear about which Tory
colleagues she's uh picking on she did
say yes look but we all don't want to
have a labor government but but nobody
could think that she's making the job of
Labor uh keeping labor from Office any
easier there is one thing however the
Tory psychodrama which you can see on
your screens now with the whatsapps that
um uh that I revealed on Wednesday the
Tory Psycho Drama just sucks up the
various uh the attempts by labor to
launch their own policy platform and get
messages out Kirsten had a very big
speech this week on Monday it's quite
notable that we weren't really spending
any time at all talking about that we
don't really and this is our bad in the
media apart from anything else we don't
really have a sense of what the
different strong opposing polls within
case dharma's Shadow cabinet are in
anything like the way that perhaps we
did when Jeremy corbyn was leaving that
we did when Tony Blair and Gordon Brown
were Prime Ministers because the Tory
Psycho Drama has been so all-consuming
this is going to end it's going to end
as we approach a general election if
labor looked like there's a serious
chance which it does at the moment uh of
there being a labor prime minister in
Downing Street we are going to have to
move away from this story psychodrama uh
which sucks all the oxygen out of the
air and and look at where the dividing
lines and the fissures and the problems
are within labor much more much more
strongly but at the moment it's the
conservative party that are falling over
themselves on the Telly like they have
been this morning to tell us how much
they hate certain other members of their
own party and how much they don't like
the policy prospectus that the
conservative prime minister is
delivering and that is just inescapably
always going to attract the attention of
the camera
let's talk about policy that might
perhaps change that I mean people keep
saying that uh migration is not such a
big issue well new figures out this week
show that net migration to the UK last
year hit a record high over 600
000. the Home Secretary said that the
figure's too high but bringing it down
could create tensions with other
ministers representing sectors that need
skilled migrants so
I asked Professor Brian Bell who's the
chair of the government's migration
advisor committee how those two strands
of thought could come together
I think there is a problem that um if if
the government says we are we have an
objective of getting net migration down
to a certain level they haven't actually
come up with an explicit number but if
they're committed to doing that you
can't then say but we need more visas on
this route we need more visas on that
route there needs to be some consistency
I think one thing that would be helpful
would be if the government focused on
the long run numbers so don't worry too
much about the fact that it was 606 000
this year we understand why that was and
the more interesting question is if you
get back to the average of about 250 000
is that acceptable and if it's not you
will have to change policy to bring it
further down
Brian Bell had a couple of rather
interesting ideas about the way that we
might uh talk about the numbers here but
in essence this is still a divisive
issue both within and between the
parties isn't it
what bribal did extremely eloquently was
to highlight that the problem for Richie
sunac is that migration is an issue that
he controls but doesn't want to the
reason that net migration figures are
high in part is because we're allowing
so many students we allow in so many
people to come and work in our
Healthcare sector as Brian Bell said we
have allowed in a large number of people
from Ukraine without commensurately
taking the same number out elsewhere
from our net migration figures these
high net migration figures are the
consequence of government choices yet
other parts of the government are saying
these numbers are too high actually
what's fascinating is the inherent
internal contradiction in and by the
government about their own policy when
it comes to this if you've got actual
levers that you could pull but very good
reasons why you don't want to because
you want students because you want to
support universities because you do need
to support the NHS Workforce then don't
say getting migration down is my top
priority using that set of Statistics
that includes the very people you are
inviting in the country I mean it's it's
kind of nonsense and yes you can in many
ways have different statistics but but
really you either have a coherent policy
here or you're or you don't and it's
different bits the conservative party
essentially once again arguing with each
other what we don't quite have a firm
grip on is the labor position and
whether or not they want to get
migration dramatically down they put an
emphasis on UK workers uh putting UK
workers first yes there is a touch of uh
you know British jobs for British
workers about it they'll never ever use
that golden brown phrase I suspect in
public they talk about Skilling up and
uh potentially raising the minimum uh
starting salary for people coming in
from abroad something I think that
Quantum Tories would like to do but do
they want to reduce numbers dramatically
well they don't say not but we'll have
to find out
Sam thanks very much that's it from us
on Sophie bridge on Sunday the take this
morning Sophie's back for the take on
Wednesday evening at 9pm
[Music]
foreign